gary you know i'm gonna say the rate at
which you can talk and the type of
you know metaphors and stuff you can put
together i think
you could rap very well i think well bro
now you're talking about something that
is the great devastation of my life of
something that doesn't matter
i
love hip hop rap so much yeah i feel
like i see what you're saying too yeah
real rappers like real guys and gals say
it to me
but there's a devastating last piece
the sheer lack of music ability i
haven't even
we're on the same page there bro
i mean you're on the same page
i'm like no no i [ __ ] this is gonna
be like literally this happened six
months ago i'm like you know what
i used to be super out of shape and not
healthy it doesn't come natural to me i
hate it more than life but over the last
eight years i got a [ __ ] babysitter
trainer i got educated of like cat like
i got a little and i i worked it i
actually achieved something that doesn't
come natural to me for sure so like nine
months ago i'm like i'm gonna do that
with rap
i don't have a musical [ __ ] bone in
my body and so like it for like a month
in the shower i'm like literally trying
to spit bars no i've got the bars i just
have no
musical
cadence at all come on like none you're
a powerful man we have to get you in
jay-z would gladly sit down with you i
mean we have to get someone to work this
out so you you've got the bars though
you're saying you have the lyrics yeah i
i know how to like i definitely know how
to say [ __ ]
gary bars cannot live and die in the
shower man they have to see the the
light of day we have to get this out
there you know you've conquered a lot of
things if we could you need to win yeah
you're right if we get polo g featuring
gary vee oh my god that would be
100
when polo g was smart enough to sample
smooth criminal i literally literally
said to myself this guy's gonna be so
uncomfortably famous
just an understanding of how humans work
the range
i was like oh this is like a different
version of drake one that i really like
i [ __ ] with polo g heavy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i do really like that song the one with
the me too because everyone listen alien
ant farm had a [ __ ] hit with it it's
[ __ ] smooth that's a good ass i
actually like that i like the alien ant
farm version more than the michael
jackson version yeah the alien am farm
version hit hard
and that's just proof i have no musical
all right so we can sidebar this but we
definitely need to get
uh apology alien ant farm
you know
and gary vee all on one track i mean
that's just you know that's my musical
goal for the year yeah you know i don't
i don't i'd really be the greatest day
of my life yeah i don't have any strings
to pull so i want to rely on you to pull
them but you know you can make it happen
well you answer a lot of our questions
already because i feel like coming in we
weren't sure we're like man
uh does gary hate us
we really weren't sure what the context
of this was because you had sent that dm
so i was like maybe he really hates us
i mean i didn't even really consider
that you might have just been blasting
it out to everyone i thought i was like
damn you know what i do when i haven't
like a post that i'm excited about
i'll just kind of go into like my inbox
and like send it like 10 or 15 people
and be like like it's kind of like a gut
check of like people that i think get it
and see like but there it's almost like
a
i thought this was good did you think
this was good kind of like vibe so that
because we dm'd
like a couple days earlier right right
right you were in that [ __ ] range
yeah
you have like 100 million hours of
video footage of you from all these
different like
talks and convent like how long have you
been filming yourself doing everything
somewhere around
somewhere around 20 what are we in 2022
i think in 17 or 18 or 16 like i was
like you know
you'll find this interesting of why i
think this is so cool yeah and you guys
are going to live this life
you are literally literally going to
have a conversation in 41 years
with one of your grandkids
around this exact video right now and
that is like [ __ ] wild yeah
yeah and so like for me it was like my
great-grandfather my grandfather both my
grandfathers died before i got to meet
them yeah and my parents who i adore
always like we have such they're only 20
years older than me like the old country
in russia you have kids early like we're
like friends not just like they're my
parents and like they give me so they
spit so much like emotional game to me
of like man you do this just like my dad
did like you know they both lost their
dads young dang and it [ __ ] i think
just weighed on me and at some level i
you know it kind of started with like
you know what
i have [ __ ] to say
i'm interested in this
i'm gonna put this on wax aka video and
like it'll be cool like if god forbid
something controversial happens to me or
even if not it'll be like fun to be like
chilling and like the like the grandkid
runs in and be like no
was cody's hair that nice i was like
yeah it was really nice
and so i think that humans right now
underestimate what's happening because
there isn't a generation for us to point
to yeah it's really [ __ ] rad that you
guys have this and you're gonna chop it
up with people in the future so i like
putting it on it's like just having
photos right like my family didn't have
a lot of photos because in russia you
didn't do that [ __ ] and so like i just
lost all this family heritage i kind of
liked that my life is filmed out and i
also like
being right and wrong i love the merit
of the game like i love the game so much
like it's fun to be like oh [ __ ] i was
right about like i secretly like wonder
like man if nfps don't win i'm gonna
have unlimited film to make fun of
myself
but i think it also in a weird way by
filming
puts me in a position of accountability
of being sharp and then finally
you know
being known
you know i'm an entrepreneur being known
leads to business opportunities right
like i want to have business
opportunities it's my game
and the more i put out good [ __ ]
the more i'm right
the more that leads to people being like
[ __ ] this dude know what the [ __ ] he's
talking about maybe we should do
business with him and that
you know that's my craft yeah well i was
gonna say we probably will chop it up
with our kids about you because
um if an asteroid hits this earth the
only footage we're going to have of
humans is just going to be gary like
we're going to lose everything else
we'll lose youtube we'll lose everything
but footage of gary will definitely be
around yeah it'll be like i gotta admit
i do [ __ ] with cockroaches i think
they're underrated
[Music]
[Applause]
you know i always say like if a nuclear
bomb comes the cockroaches win i'm like
i'm gonna be [ __ ]
you know so i think maybe that's what
i'm doing
hell yeah man this is gonna be a
probably a really boring question for
everyone else but
for everyone listening right now but my
favorite podcast ever is how i built
this
and so when i listened to your episode
that was the first time that i really
got that side of you where you were just
kind of like yeah i like to be made fun
of
and i and i got like the back story with
the wine and stuff like that and i i
suggest everyone go listen to that
because it was like one of my favorite
episodes but i want to know is guy raz
just like the absolute [ __ ] man dude
he's such a strong like you know it was
funny
you and like this is back to like the
way i put out content so you know the
way i put out content no question has
baggage that comes along with it which
is
in that format it's incredibly difficult
to show depth right and i'm incredibly
talking about like what tick tocks and
like well the tips like the joke the
joke stuff's on a planet by itself but
even like the stuff that isn't like
funny or like the menta gary or like the
funny analogies like even just my
business content in 45 seconds you can
only do so much damage right really it's
a moose boost to try to get you to dig
deeper and then go into the longer form
how i built this emails and they're like
three hours and i'm like get the [ __ ]
out i'm like i'm so like 15 minutes
seven minute meet like i go hard and
fast
three hours and i i kind of said no to
myself and my team i was like yeah
you know it's a it's the one of the best
but i don't know if i've got three hours
for it right there's too much going on
and then i kind of slept on it i was
like yeah i just like guy a lot his
energy's so awesome it is such a great
show i was like [ __ ] it let's do it and
in hindsight it was a remarkably good
thing because listen it no matter how
built much built you are to be able to
deal with
judgment and not you don't give a [ __ ]
every human cares and
you know even if you're good at taking
jokes or you're good at people
misunderstanding and i'm really good at
it i just really am it's how i'm built
that's my mom's doing that's my growing
up and the gutter doing there's a lot
that got me there i'd be lying if i
didn't say i'm really glad i did that
show because i am flabbergasted by how
many people have come up to me emailed
me dm me and said you know what that
podcast put the final tease in like
there was things that were missing that
i heard in there that give me a
different point of view and that's like
listen it's nice like why wouldn't you
want somebody to think fondly of you
versus you suck yeah yeah
damn